if you're publishing in the scientific
literature
you need to be aware of the problem of
predatory open access journals
open access journals are bogus journals
that are exploiting the open access
model to make money
open access journals are a great idea
the idea is that authors pay publishing
fees so that journals can make the full
text of articles freely
available to everyone the plos journals
public library of science journals are
shining examples of this open access
publishing model
when it's done with integrity open
access publishing is fantastic
but because money is exchanging hands
this has opened the floodgates for the
creation of bogus journals which exist
solely to collect money from authors
not to publish high quality research
jeffrey beale a librarian at the
university of colorado
denver has been a leader in calling out
this practice and keeping lists of bad
publishers and bad journals
another leader in exposing this whole
problem is the journalist john bohannon
he ran a sort of sting operation that he
wrote about in science in 2013
what he did was he submitted an
obviously flawed bogus paper
he describes it as he did a scientific
version of mad libs
so that he could come up with 255
slightly different versions of the same
paper where he took molecule x from
lichen species y inhibits the growth of
cancer cell z
he created a whole bunch of different
papers just substituting different
molecules and species in cancer cells
and the papers had obvious flaws any
scientist
no matter how schooled should have been
able to look at figure one and know that
this paper was problematic
he submitted this to open access
journals many of which he suspected to
be predatory journals
and indeed of 255 where he got a
decision back
157 of those journals accepted that
paper
it was only rejected by 98 in fact
82 percent of the publishers on jeffrey
beale's list
actually accepted that paper so john
bohannon was able to show that there is
this huge suite out there of predatory
journals
and they are willing to accept anything
for money
along with the report science published
a map that shows the location of
publishers
editors and their bank accounts
color-coded by acceptance or rejection
of the paper
the locations were derived from ip
address traces within the raw headers of
emails
who is registrations and bank invoices
for publication fees
india emerged as the world's largest
base for fee charging open access
publishing
64 publishers and over 90 percent of
them accepted the paper
the united states is the next largest
base with 29 publishers accepting the
paper and 26 rejecting it
in africa nigeria has the largest number
of which 100
accepted the paper
all evidence shows us that these
predatory journals are greatly on the
rise
there was a 2015 paper in bmc medicine
that tracked predatory journals from
2010 to 2014.
you can see it's growing exponentially
pay attention to that red line on top
that's the total number of predatory
journals
they estimated that in 2014 there were
about 8 000 active predatory journals
in 2010 these journals published about
53 000
articles that was up to 420 000
articles published in these predatory
journals in 2014
these are probably all or most of poor
quality
authors paid an average article
processing charge of 178 u.s dollars per
article
so it's a money-making scam that same
paper they also shared that this affects
all scientific disciplines
in 2013 declan butler this checklist in
nature to help you vet journals
to make sure that you're being careful
to not submit to one of these predatory
journals
he suggested that authors should check
that the publisher provides full
verifiable contact information you want
the full address of the publisher to be
available
you also want to check that the journals
editorial board lists actual experts
with full affiliations
not just made up people you might even
want to contact them and ask them about
their experience with the publisher
because there are known instances when
people's names have been borrowed and
just stuck on these websites without the
person's permission
you want to check that the journal
prominently displays its policy for
author fees
open access journals do charge fees but
you want to make sure that these
policies are clearly described on their
website
if they're not that's a suspicious sign
be wary of spam
email invitations you will get a lot of
these emails that ask you to submit to
journals or to become an editorial board
member
or to speak at a conference you can tell
that these are spam if you look
carefully
always go to the journal's website and
make sure that the articles that they
are publishing are high quality articles
check that a journal's peer review
process is clearly described
make sure that they are actually doing
peer review and try to find out whether
a journal's claimed
impact factor is correct there is a
trend now where these predatory journals
are making up bogus metrics
they have names like the universal
impact factor uif
or the global impact factor gif or the
journal impact factor
jif these are all popular but bogus
metrics made up by predatory journals
they sound a lot like the real thing so
be careful not to get sucked into that
there are lists people publish of
supposedly legitimate open access
journals
the lists are not perfect but at least
the journals listed there have gone
through some vetting
you might want to check before
submitting you can check with the
directory of open access
journals or the open access scholarly
publishers association
you can check there and make sure that
the journal you're submitting to is
listed there
finally use common sense if something
looks fishy
if it looks like spam it probably is
so just be careful and be aware of these
predatory journals